there were some elections last night
mostly primaries and we'll talk about
those later but an incredible if you
haven't been paying attention result
from last night is that kansas voters
deep
dark red kansas voters have voted to
keep
abortion legal in the state of kansas
and the reason i say if you haven't been
paying attention it would be shocking
is that we know from public opinion
polls that now there is more support for
abortion being legal in most cases in
the united states than at any point
since the start of the roe v wade era
and so when the supreme court a few
weeks ago overturned roe v wade nine
people voted and six of them decided to
overturn roe v wade it is not
representative or reflective of the will
of the people of the united states
we now are seeing the proof of that in
this vote from kansas the associated
press reporting kansas voters
resoundingly protect their access to
abortion
reading
kansas voters sent a resounding message
about their desire to protect abortion
rights rejecting a ballot measure in a
conservative state with deep ties to the
anti-abortion movement that would have
allowed the republican-controlled
legislature to tighten restrictions or
ban abortion outright this was the first
test of voter sentiment after the u.s
supreme court's decision in june which
overturned the constitutional right to
an abortion providing an unexpected
result with potential implications for
the coming midterm elections the
implications here are numerous first and
foremost oh uh the vote
um the
by 20 points
the vote um was to
keep uh to reject the amendment which
would have allowed anything up to making
abortion illegal so a 20-point victory
for the pro-choice side in the deep dark
red state of kansas now we've known for
some time
that americans generally want abortion
to be legal now i know there are many
people who desperately want abortion to
be illegal
but consider the circumstances in the
united states over time the country has
become more and more in favor of legal
abortion in most cases and the country
has become less and less religious and
we know that one of the main groups that
is against abortion
is those who are
religious of a very particular kind
we're talking about evangelical
christians we're talking about
conservative catholics etc that group
has shrunk over time there has been
shrinkage
and we have seen support for abortion
increase now there are non-religious
people who are also against abortion no
no problem but the main opposition to
abortion in the united states is
religiously based so these are not
surprising numbers
the
connection to the november midterms
that's being made here is a very very
important one
tomorrow assuming everything goes right
things get a little crazy sometimes for
rachel bittikoffer and sometimes
interviews get rescheduled but i'm
scheduled to speak with political
scientist rachel bittikoffer tomorrow
the signs are increasingly pointing to
this year
abortion rights and gun safety being
good issues for democrats to run on
typically running on abortion rights and
gun safety regulations is not good for
democrats if anything it doesn't do
anything to activate democrats but it
does a lot to activate republicans to
come out and vote against whoever is
supporting abortion rights and
supporting gun safety regulations the
polling we've seen so far
already suggested this year those might
be winning issues for democrats
the results in kansas
further suggest that that indeed might
be the case now you should be prepared
and it's already happening
for
anti-choice advocates
right wingers
kooky reactionaries all the normal
people that you would expect
to come out and say that the reason this
vote went the way it did in kansas is
for something other than
people just generally want abortion to
be available in most cases doesn't mean
you have to get one or anybody in
particular has to get one but it's
available as an option for you and your
doctors to determine is the right one
for you
and they are already going out of their
way to say this was about other things
and i'm not gonna plague you with these
examples but here's one from fox news
where they made it out to be
basically
the pro-choice people bought these
results by spending a whole bunch of
money it's not reflective of the actual
perspective on abortion in the united
states here's one example ansys
referendum is very interesting i do
think that pro-lifers should understand
that so much money was spent by hardcore
abortion supporters to make sure that
that amendment failed it also was a
pretty um there's a lot that was
packaged there and i think that usually
pro-life initiatives do much better when
they're incremental
and so it's a reminder also that as roe
v wade was overturned and abortion
law and policy is returned to the states
where people get to weigh in there's a
lot of work to be done for people who
want to protect women and children from
the scourge of abortion or people who
want to make sure that it is enshrined
in law so
so there's a lot more to be done there
and we'll see a lot more in the years to
come so that's molly hemingway from the
federalist and she's actually completely
wrong it is not about any of those
things people are less religious than
ever people are more in favor of
abortion being legal in most cases than
ever the primary opposition to abortion
is on religious grounds and they are
just out of step with the will of the
american people that's what's going on
and listen
it's kansas if kansas is
deep down actually against abortion
being legal
you're not going to be able to spend
your way to a victory the way that she's
suggesting the pro-choice movement would
be able to do there are people who want
low taxes
low regulation to the extent that they
even i mean listen i'm being charitable
to the extent they even know what these
things mean you can be for
low taxes and low regulation and you
know
not teaching transgender in schools even
whatever that means but still have come
around on the fact that abortion should
probably be legal in most cases and
that's what's going on so tomorrow
we'll talk to rachel bittikoffer and get
her thoughts about what this potentially
means for the november election
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor i'm thrilled about
because i sleep on a helix mattress at
home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is you
don't have to guess which mattress do i
need which one will be good for me you
take their famous sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position your
back pain issues you might have and they
will pair you with a mattress that will
be perfect for you i took the sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what i needed i often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and i've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so don't get
stuck with something that's not perfect
for you and all helix mattresses come
with a 10-year warranty and they'll even
come to your house and pick it up within
a hundred days if you don't love it but
i think you will for a limited time
helix is offering up to 350 off all
mattress orders plus two free pillows at
helixsleep.com pacman it's the biggest
discount they've ever offered the link
is down below